why is it hard for people to let go of
what's so familiar with to them even if
it's bad
well because it's complicated you know
and the thing that's a really good
question you discount the risk of
familiarity that they're familiar with
so like let's say because people are in
relationships people are in
relationships with drugs and alcohol
people in relationships with humans
people are in relationships with jobs
people in relationships with their own
selves and they deliver they're living a
lie every single day but it's
familiarity yeah well you say I have a
job I hate
it's like well yeah but I'm not dying
from it it's like not as bad as it can
be so you kind of you kind of you
factored in the risks already they get
invisible and think well I can't jump
out of this job because what about all
the risk it's like yeah no kidding
you've got to make a you got to get your
resume in order you got to send it out
you got to send 50 of the damn things
out before anybody will call you back
then you have to go get interviewed and
maybe you're not any good at that you
have to come up with a story while
you're a good employee and maybe and
maybe you're not yet so you have to
figure out how to do that it's like what
about all these risks if I go look for a
new job it's like yeah absolutely man
those are risks and they're harsh and no
wonder you're avoiding them what about
the risks for you to stay with this job
you absolutely hate well let's think
that through okay so I have this
dead-end job I hate it I'm getting
better where am I going to be in five
years I know where because I've watched
this with people
you're going to be
you're going to be just like you are now
except a lot more of what's good about
you is going to be gone and a lot more
of what's terrible is going to be
Amplified and you're going to be like in
five years you're going to be 10 years
older instead of three years older yeah
right because it kills your spirits oh
man yeah so it's like you think oh my
God there's a terrible risk in pursuing
this new job it's like yeah there is a
terrible risk
there's a terrible risk and you stand
with your job right now and so one of
the things that's really really freeing
to understand is that you're screwed no
matter what you do ah there's no secure
path forward
give it up it's risk everywhere it's
like oh my God that's terrible it's like
yes except for two things
you can pick your risk
that's the first thing so you get to
pick your poison that's something and
second you're a lot tougher than you
think so even though there's risk
everywhere if you confront it
forthrightly what you'll find is that
you can actually handle the risk and
that's the security
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one